[Music]
in muggshot news Oh what the hell have I
submitted by Bob da builder can we fix
it yes wow I've never heard that song
with the [ __ ] of the Builder I only knew
cuz my brothers yeah and I really like
what is this like some kind of like
Mexican Home Depot song what is what its
gonna yellow on blue guy Bob Quan oh my
bad baba I've never heard of a Mexican
named Bob but it could be what his
name's Roberta would call him Baba cops
used facial recognition technology to
catch 25 wanted criminals at a beer
festival well like they went to like a
beer what are those what they do they're
like scanning the place I guess it is if
you're in a public space and your face
is it's kind of different when you're
drinking alone right okay you don't I
mean like your muscles were relaxing in
weird ways
yeah no I'm always like very focused
when I drink because I tried trying to
act like I'm not drunk at all yeah so
I'm like like that kind of [ __ ] yeah I
look angry I've been told that many
times so so 25 wanted individuals were
arrested when they showed up to this
Chinese beer festival oh that's not
that's not a good idea just Chinese beer
festivals hell of a disaster what's
Chinese beer like a chain like Qingdao
yeah it was a in that thing tell
toontown it's PS ing right and in ta I
was cute Qi and Zhi Bao Ginga Qingdao
have you had J it's super cheap and it's
really good whenever
I've heard of good room so yeah they all
showed up at this beer festival and they
caught these people because there were
18 cameras installed at four entrances
of the festival have these like facial
recognition cameras they were able to
identify each of these suspects in under
one second by running their face under
like police data the database and so
they caught 25 of these these guys and
one of these guys were wanted for over
ten years
wow what a shadow beer festival cotton
and what were they what were they wars a
crime they didn't mention the 25 people
but just that one person felt like kung
fu in public or something they must have
knew that these guys were gonna come for
them instead of 18 face recognition
cameras did they throw the festival just
to capture conjured by the FBI like 25
wanted criminals and how many people
come to a beer festival but the thing is
China so probably a lot so you met that
many about 40,000 so like I'm thinking
of festivals in LA where it's like
hunter people go because everyone's like
I'm staying inside yeah and they're
saying that there are also dozens of
other people with criminal records or a
history of drug abuse that will refuse
entrance to the festival as well after
the computer spotted wow you keep all
the like pedophiles and like wanted
people out of the festival
I'd be down this is why I'm cold
that's even worse this one grant
computers are in charge of that job
because if that was me I'd be like oh
that's him that's him to get that guy
China they all look the same I don't
[ __ ] know I don't know the difference
of I said I did the same thing about
white people I'm like they look the same
that's him that's him I'm like they're
brothers and they did mention of their
six officers stationed at each of the
entrances so they could verify the
matches and they're saying that this
system has a ninety eight point one
percent accuracy pretty [ __ ] low I
can be 1.80 like wait dozen 21.8 I kept
thinking wow that's not that accurate
right you said 98.1 I like it all right
91 plate I don't know about that would
you buy a condom that's 2% off exactly
right I think our condoms are one
no they're 99.9 Oh would you buy a home
that's 98% of home yes thank God who
built it
a piece of the garage is like it's great
take it that's great we need that in the
US we need that every supermarket every
restaurant anywhere we go more police
and we need a police there no guns take
away all of our guns and it's simple
cameras everywhere no man I see TV is
like everywhere in Japan and and you're
up - yeah there's one camera there's
more cameras than people there or
something yeah I don't know who's
watching because I don't even know if I
could keep track of all of that stuff
like maybe that's just used for like if
you have to rewind and see if something
happened you know on the eighth block of
whatever it's helped out a lot of people
though I know like in Korea they have
like CCTV everywhere and people always
have like con people but you can't cuz
like a camera every [ __ ] corner like
all the insurance fraud or run in front
of moving vehicles those Russian yeah
there was one of this guy who like runs
in front of a car and then like he like
like that slow fall yeah yeah yeah
basically and then he's like I have a
camera like thing and I guys like all
the [ __ ] you ruin this day my business
it's how you in the town
anyways yeah so it was pretty cool I I
don't know I feel like if I was going to
major event and they had these cameras
set up I'd feel safe yeah cuz it's kind
of like not infringing on your rights of
privacy because you're going to a public
thing and you're agreeing to go but if
it's kind of like forced upon you then
it's kind of questionable maybe I say
put machines in charge of all this [ __ ]
including the airport because like how
many people get racially profile at the
airport right what if a [ __ ] machine
is doing that [ __ ] how can a machine
race should profile you did you guys see
it not anyone oh yeah the hand soap
thing would only react to like
light-skinned or white colors so then
like a black guy put his hand under the
soap machine and it wouldn't come out
they didn't program it to recognize dark
skin Wow you see in the South Park game
the difficulty slider because you take
the you go from easy to more like hard
your skin gets darker for what game for
there's a South Park game no new one
that's coming out and they made the
Divis sound purpose yeah yeah because
like obviously like the darker life is
harder the dark New York oh like a game
of life yeah no no it's just the game
where you're creating your own character
and in the slide video game yeah in the
slider yeah the more difficult the game
is the the darker your skin is all the
way to like hard black that sucks yeah
I don't know I think the whole camera
thing a lot of people here will be
against it because it's like super
paranoid about government controlling
everything yeah in certain places like a
stadium or like places that can be
targeted easily by a you know and then
there's not enough personnel that can
handle it
we should have machines do that for that
but you know why if we say it won't fly
here right but then in the next breath
we don't I don't see anyone pushing for
that you know why because we have camera
and microphone in our pockets oh and if
people will do it yeah so we're fine
already like the government's like we
don't need to push for this guy's
probably we got we've got 300 million
surveilling people you know as intimate
as we want we get them all on the toilet
what about the criminals that
carry their phone around and they just
thought it would give me master
criminals yeah they're under the radar
well this facial recognition thing is
pretty cool too to spot people that are
missing
yeah like children that yeah I know they
do it all at the Vegas casinos they do
they have a huge list of people that are
banned and then they all share the same
black book so like if you got caught
card counting or drew Ben Affleck for
example if you get kicked out of a
casino they all share the same thing so
if you're blacklisted from one if
they're all across the nation so like if
you walk in and then they register they
go oh this guy take them out dude Ben
Affleck is on the banned list at
Caesar's Palace really yes because
counting cards for real dude yeah do it
what did you just walk through the door
like this or with a beer in your hand
like that I mean eventually you're gonna
take you put your lift your head up and
then it's rigged all over the cap oh you
even admitted to counting card I mean
it's not illegal at the Hard Rock Hotel
yeah counting cards isn't illegal you're
just using your brain to do math but
he's banned now right like I thought it
was illegal to count cards counting
cards isn't illegal
it's it's perfectly legal so they find
out you're counting cars and winning all
those money they're not gonna do [ __ ]
no they're just gonna they just refuse
business to you they just refuse it but
they don't they can't send you to jail
but if you're cheating though they take
that serious in Vegas you could do like
years there's like guys that like
packing like a slot machines and [ __ ]
like that and then they're doing like 20
years like murderers get away before
they do yeah money yeah
cheating is crowning cards is perfect
yeah cuz all you're doing is using math
in your mind like they can't tell me
don't don't be too smart okay don't
don't don't do that and and you're not
cheating you're not doing anything
you're just like based off of all the
cards that came out you're just keeping
track exact sum there's some with one
deck yeah but yeah I mean if they're not
having it face up you don't know the
probability even if it's I mean at four
decks it's still easy you could still
count cards and you just basically look
at what came out and then you kind of
predict okay well it's probably gonna be
better probability so I better make my
bet higher
it's super simple but they don't like
that because it's yeah that's kind of
what we do already when we see too many
aces out we know we're not going to the
blackjack later yeah so you just pay the
minimum and then just yeah hey guys
would you think of that video I know you
loved it so make sure to hit that like
button to watch more videos check it out
up here
[Music]